today's video is brought to you by
masterworks here at visualpolitik we
have built quite an amazing community
and today we're going to tell you about
another interesting community they're
300 000 strong and growing it's a
community that buys unique pieces of art
with masterworks dot io if you don't
recall here's a quick recap masterworks
is the only investing platform
democratizing this exclusive asset class
valued at a whopping 1.7 trillion
dollars they give people like you and me
access to the type of investment that
millionaires and billionaires both old
and new money have been enjoying for
generations so what is the attraction of
art as an investment well one ubs
reports that two-thirds of
high-net-worth collectors buy art for an
expected return on investment two real
assets like art typically appreciate
well when inflation is high in fact
historically art has proven to be a very
good tool for protecting against
inflation contemporary art returned 23.2
during periods with over three percent
inflation while the s p 500 returned 3.8
and three blue chip art prices outpaced
the s p 500 by 164 between 1995 to 2021.
as always and everything related to
investment tread carefully nothing is
risk-free so join masterworks today by
using our link below to get priority
access and now let's get on with the
video after donald trump's victory over
hillary clinton the brexit referendum
and the alt-right spreading its
tentacles over half of europe france's
2017 presidential election was seen by
many as the last bastion against
populism in favor of civility and
tolerance now five years later history
is repeating itself on the eve of the
french presidential election many
candidates and journalists are bringing
up the country's great history and its
extensive commitment to human rights of
course the reality may be somewhat
different and much less epic as general
de gaulle said france cannot be france
without greatness whatever the cost
because you can be very clear about one
thing france's foreign policy is not
exactly straightforward so the question
is has france always been the beacon of
democracy that gallic politicians claim
it is why are france's actions seen so
differently from outside of france to
how the french themselves see them from
within i'll tell you now visualpolitik
fans this video is going to be a little
bit different from our usual ones on
this occasion we will focus on some of
the major scandals that have had
international repercussions in france
this is the other side of the french
republic check this out
[Music]
coup d'etat campaigns of repression
kidnappings and assassination france's
foreign policy is not always based on
soft diplomacy dialogue and the free
exchange of viewpoints today we will
look at some of the alleged major
international scandals in which the
french republic might have been involved
scandals that have fueled all kinds of
suspicions conspiracy theories and
resentment some of them are flatly
denied by paris even though there are
many reasons to doubt their claims on
the other hand there are some that are
admitted but under their breath having
said that without further ado i think
it's time to bring some of them to light
and guess what the first one takes us
all the way to latin america
[Music]
operation condor
during the 1970s a large chunk of south
america was under the control of
dictatorships that ruled the countries
with an iron fist we are particularly
talking about brazil argentina chile
paraguay bolivia and uruguay well the
fact is that on the 28th of november
1975 in santiago chile the governments
of these countries with the exception of
brazil although this did not prevent it
from participating actively officially
implemented what is known as operation
condor operation condor was a campaign
of political repression and state
terrorism to persecute the political
opposition particularly the left-wing
opposition we are talking about a harsh
campaign of repression in which at one
time or another most of the governments
of south america participated and which
included the assassination of numerous
political opponents terror swept to the
southern continent from top to bottom
and did so with the strong support of
the united states under the
administrations of jared ford jimmy
carter and ronald reagan
tens of thousands of irregular arrests
kidnappings and extraditions were
carried out over a period of more than
10 years torture was widely used and
some estimates suggest that more than 60
000 deaths can be attributed to planned
condor victims included left-wing
guerillas but also political dissidents
union leaders students intellectuals
teachers priests and peasants
[Music]
well history tells us that the south
american government's carried out this
plan mainly with the support of the
united states this is the story but wait
a minute because it might not be the
whole story particularly if we're
talking about argentina and chile
you see the point is that as has been
reported some original documents from
the french foreign ministry seemed to
prove an agreement in 1959 between paris
and buenos aires to establish a
permanent military mission of french
officers in argentina who had previously
fought in the algerian war it is also
suspected that president gascard's
government actively and secretly
collaborated with the videla junta in
argentina and the augusto pinochet
regime in chile in this way the french
would have trained the intelligence
services of the argentine dictatorship
including training in torture techniques
not only that the annihilation decrees
signed by isabel perron seem to have
been inspired by earlier french
documents
[Music]
general ronaldo bignon himself appointed
president of the argentine military
junta in 1982 stated that the order of
battle of the coup d'etat that brought
the argentine military to power in 1976
have been inspired by france's own
experience in algeria
so it's as clear as day then years later
in 2003 the french green party deputies
called for the creation of a
parliamentary commission to examine
france's role in actively supporting
military regimes in south america a
commission that got nowhere because the
head of the commission rule and bloom
refused to allow key witnesses to
testify
so basically the french government has
actively denied having played any role
in planned condor however there are many
reasons to doubt them in 2007 argentine
admiral luis maria mendia declared in
court that the french intelligence had
participated in the kidnapping and
murder of two french nuns and this is
just one example what is certain is that
despite paris's constant denials the
evidence seems to be piling up on the
table but do you know what we've only
just begun because there is one
territory in which french diplomacy
really excels and we are talking about
africa check this out
[Music]
the gaelic theater of operations
it has been more than six decades more
than 60 years since france's colonies in
africa began to become independent
despite this however the role of the
french nation on the african continent
remains so strong that it even has its
own name frank gaffree we are talking
about a concept that tries to bring
together both the political influence of
france and the influence of the
clandestine networks full of corruption
and shady dealings that continue to
exist between the old empire and its
former colonies or rather with the
elites with the elites who control their
former colonies be that as it may if
there is one thing that has always been
clear to the french government it is its
determination to maintain its
international influence and continue to
be considered a world superpower and
africa plays a key role in that strategy
and so although 60 years have passed
france's presence influence and power in
the region is still enormous plain and
simple
we are talking about a role that during
the cold war was supported by the united
states itself why because during the
cold war france became the spearhead the
last stronghold of the west to prevent
the region from falling under soviet
influence a role that paris took very
much to heart to give you an idea france
played such an interventionist role in
africa that from 1960 to the
mid-1990s it led an average of one
military intervention every year that's
right an average of one intervention per
year it is something that practically
leaves the united states and george w
bush himself as true beginners in the
whole matter of international
interventions
france has done practically everything
on the african continent from
intervening to protect french citizens
and putting down rebellions to
preventing coup d'etats to facilitating
coup d'etats it has not even hesitated
to eliminate presidents who posed a
threat to its plans for example here is
a list of african presidents whose
elimination france is suspected to have
participated in
yes most of them may have been
full-blown tyrants but this gives you an
idea of how france has played its part
in the region and we can't say that the
results have been particularly good
either if we leave aside france's own
interests of course so much talk about
the chinese in africa but then sacred
blue
to carry out this strategy not one but
not two but three french intelligence
services have played a very active role
in organizing coup d'etats and purging
uncomfortable or hostile leaders the
documentation and foreign anti-espionage
service the dgse and the dst
[Music]
and that is not all the truth is that we
can find many more examples of very very
controversial actions
[Music]
for example there is the case of the
notorious angolaki a huge political
scandal related to the secret sale and
shipment of arms to the angolan
government during the 1990s a scandal
that involved many of the most
high-ranking figures in french politics
from mittoran to jacques chirac
an even darker case is that of the 1995
murder of bernard burrell a french
magistrate stationed in djibouti who to
this day by all indications was
dispatched by the diabetes government
itself and you know what since at that
time it was in france's interest to take
care of their relationship with this
african country well everything suggests
that it advised this african government
on how to prepare its defence while also
leaking important information to them
about the police and judicial
investigations that were underway
[Music]
and take note because france has been
condemned for this whole affair first in
2015 by the european court of human
rights and later in 2020 by a paris
court for interfering in the
investigation and pressuring the defense
of bernard burrell's widow
you know justice and human rights are
first and foremost viva france another
well-documented case and not very well
known and proof that sometimes
operations designed in offices thousands
of kilometers away end very badly is
precisely that of rwanda i'm referring
to how france in a certain way favored
our help to the government that
participated in the 1994 genocide you
see france actively supported the
hutu-led government to the extent that
it provided arms and military training
to the hutu militants weapons and
preparations that the hutus used shortly
thereafter to massacre between half a
million and a million tootsie citizens
in just a few months but africa is not
the only theater of operations in which
france has faced strong controversy a
very very recent example is the war in
yemen
leclerc tanks shells mirage 2009
fighters cobra raiders aravis armored
vehicles cougars and dolphin helicopters
mcaf frigates a missile corvette and
caesar guns this is part of the long
list of french military equipment used
by saudi arabia in the yemen war and
despite repeated public denials by the
french government everything points to
the fact that france has opened its arms
catalogue white to the saudis in order
to make a profit out of this war a war
where the safety of civilians is never a
priority
and not only that there are many
indications that france also trained and
gave logistical support to saudi arabia
while publicly denying it there are even
credible reports that france went so far
as to supply special forces in yemen
under the utmost secret
french special forces on the ground in
yemen le figaro in short we could go on
with more and more cases
[Music]
and you see the truth is that although
the mainstream media always focuses on
the scandals and alleged excesses of
countries like the united states or
israel the old continent of europe also
has plenty of its own and in the
particular case of france its status as
an influential country in global affairs
is something it has been able to
maintain in exchange for let's say not
always respecting and promoting human
rights transparency and justice its
influence and let's not fool ourselves
also the business of its very
significant military industry this is
the true price of france's greatness so
what do you think of france's foreign
policy how do you assess its role in
africa do you believe that the pursuit
of interests and benefits of various
kinds justifies any intervention leave
us your answers in the comments below
and if you like this video don't forget
to like and subscribe to all of us here
at visualpolitik thanks very much for
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]